i put out on twitter the what is that i
don't know chris sims statement that
tyree kill is the best receiver in the
nfl here's what i tweeted yeah very
objective did not take any shots at you
for a change chris sims thinks tyree
kill is the best receiver in the nfl do
you agree that's a fair and you didn't
take any shots of it because you agree
too i do agree okay i didn't put myself
on the line though because i didn't want
to be lumped into all the comments
yeah okay all all the unqualified people
of the world come here and come at me
because it's so stupid what was the
first comment i mean chris sims is a
clown yeah chris sims is a clown
that was me i'm sorry
how dare he take the fastest most
explosive offensive weapon in the game i
know chris sims is a clown what an idiot
he is to pick the the most dangerous guy
in the sport right now i mean he's
fourth in receiving yards in football
out of all the top receivers he's best
in average yards per catch and he has
six touchdown receptions which leads the
nfl with antonio brown and i would say
that yes he has weapons around him but
his his next best receiver isn't as good
as juju smith schuster like sammy
watkins isn't as good as juju so you
know i just you know i just represent
that guy's comment take it back guy
apologize on twitter i i i see names
like michael thomas that they're all i'm
just i'm stealing sure sure but they're
crazy are you antonio brown hey awesome
but i mean i'm not taking adam thielen
and here's michael thomas over tyreek
hill if you could take any of those guys
it doesn't necessarily make him the best
receiver if you could take any of those
guys which one would you take and it's
tyree kill because of how he affects the
rest of the audience exactly it's it's a
it's a like he is the kind of guy that
keeps a defense coordinator up and has
nightmares because he goes what are we
going to do to defend this guy and he
does it to the special teams coaches too
because they have to worry about kick
returns and punt returns occasionally
you have to worry about so many things
with him he's a special player i think
we just all my point was we got to start
putting him in that conversation it's
that time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports